I think most people know exactly what
New York values are but you're from New
York City might not
[Music]
another day another GOP primary debate
with Donald Trump center stage so how'd
the candidates fare without
self-described libertarian - Senator
Rand Paul in the mix anymore pull up a
seat and take a load off because we've
watched hours of this stuff to distill
down for you only the best and worst
moments of the South Carolina GOP debate
listen there's a real difference between
Marcos tax plan and mine mine gives
every American a simple flat tax of 10%
Marcos top tax rate is 35 percent
Americans hate the tax system and most
mistrust the IRS so it was refreshing to
hear an actual substantive discussion of
tax reform from many of the candidates
I'm not gonna have something that Ted
described in this tax plan is called the
value of value-added tax it is a tax you
find in many companies in Europe where
basically businesses now will have to
pay a tax both on the money they make
but they also have to pay taxes on the
money they pay their employees and
that's why they have it in Europe
because it's a way to blindfold the
people even Ben Carson's shook himself
awake long enough to point out that
taxation tends to hit the poor far
harder than it does the wealthy every
regulation is a tax it's a on goods and
services and it's the most regressive
tax that there is you know when you go
into the store buy a box of laundry
detergent and the price has gone up you
know 50 cents because of regulations a
poor person notices that a rich person
does not I would certainly start taxing
goods that come in from China who the
hell has to lose 500 billion dollars
Donald Trump did what Donald Trump does
best bluster against China I'm a free
trader I believe it but we have to be
smart and we have to use smart people to
negotiate but some candidates on stage
pushed back and pointed out that tariffs
don't just punish our supposed enemies
they punish American consumer
I think we need to be very careful with
tariffs and here's why China doesn't pay
the tariff the buyer pays the tariff if
you send the tie or a shirt made in
China into the United States and
American goes to buy it at the store and
there's a tariff on it it gets passed on
in the price to the consumer
they'll be retaliation yeah you think
that the Chinese if they had a forty
five percent tariff imposed on all their
imports wouldn't retaliate and start
buying Airbus of course they would the
military is not ready either we need to
rebuild our military and this president
has let it diminish to a point where
tin-pot dictator like the mullahs in
Iran are taking our Navy ships
Republicans always talk a big game about
cutting spending except when it comes to
the military and this debate was no
different if I'm president of the United
States and Congress tries to cut the
military I will veto that in a
millisecond remember this is despite the
fact that the u.s. spends more on its
military than the next seven nations
combined
I will gladly accept the mantle of anger
there's nothing Donald Trump can say to
shock anyone anymore
but doubling down on his all-out Muslim
ban was a particularly shameful moment
in this debate is there anything you've
heard that makes you want to rethink
this position no and I have many great
Muslim friends and some of them I will
say not all have called me and said
Donald thank you very much you're
exposing an unbelievable problem we
should put the NSA in charge of the
civilian side of this as well that
expertise needs to spread all across the
government without Rand Paul's
dissenting voice in the mix the National
Security portion of this debate quickly
devolved into an NSA love fest what we
want to do is to control this we also
want to dominate this from a commercial
side Edward Snowden is a traitor and if
I am president and we get our hands on
this president doesn't enforce the
marijuana laws in this country because
he doesn't agree with them and he allows
states to go ahead and do whatever they
want beyond the usual war on
fill-in-the-blank
you know we have a war on virtually
everything race Wars gender Wars income
Wars religious wars age force every war
you can imagine we have people at each
other's throats this debate saw an
especially chill wind blowing through
the battle planes of local law
enforcement there's a chill wind blowing
through law enforcement in this country
the police are the most mistreated
people in this country I will tell you
that despite FBI statistics showing the
police have never been safer in history
agree disagree just don't care let us
know in the comments
[Music]